foreign
they are elected leaders responsible for
the direction of the Clark County School
District but watching a CCSD meeting can
seem more like just watching a reality
show constant arguments both in person
and on social media and as our 8 news
now investigators found out it's costing
taxpayers money our David charn's here
now with why David Brian Denise the
trustees have hired help to try to mend
things and get along but as you will see
these sessions you are paying for they
don't appear to be working
Cassie Ford you are not the president
you're not running the meeting so please
you are a hypocrite I'm gonna go tweet
about it hypocrite
she's just gonna tweet about it
okay so they're public moments
highlighting a school board in chaos
just to afford for the offer how about
you put that on your campaign website
okay trustees we are not doing this
absolutely not uh we will shut down the
lines if you two cannot communicate
professionally infighting among the
Clark County School Board of Trustees
seen in full View and posted online what
can I do to help you
um improve your social media habits
because it's taking this entire
organization and the group dynamics but
the seven trustees have tried to get
along at least through trainings costing
Clark County taxpayers thousands they
use now investigators filing public
records requests with CCSD to find out
how much invoices revealing at least
four sessions cost to combined fifteen
thousand dollars the biggest charge 8
500 to learn quote skills and strategies
work better as a board and help
individual trustees meet their
individual needs
this was trustee Katie Williams just
last week this board is absolutely
insane it's it's completely off the
rails and do you think that any
superintendent worth his weight in gold
or her weight in gold right uh is gonna
want to come to this District after we
have
constantly put ourselves on display I
think my interaction is just fine in
fact that's what I was voted for trustee
Daniel Ford is often the most outspoken
this tweet from May directed to trustee
Williams saying shut the expletive up
this was a meeting in June I will tell
them to f off
but they do that again I will absolutely
go on social media where I know that
anybody could see it if they wanted to
and speak the truth about what happened
or set the record straight Ford says the
district is spending even more money on
training sessions she says are not
beneficial she tells us she'd rather sit
and learn about policy and law we don't
get any training on that all of our
training is just be quiet why are you
being rude you should be nice to the
other members of the board
there's a road map now in front of you
that you can choose to move forward on
in May the board talked about the
policies it paid to develop notes and
recommendations include not to post
individually on social media and instead
quote speaking with one voice to send a
clear message on the priorities and
progress of District goals there are
many issues that we have interpersonally
with each other we fail to constantly
address them or we address them
ineffectively with fifteen thousand
dollars spent on the sessions we found
invoices for
this was board president Irene cepeda's
response just this past summer it is
insane that I spent so much time
disciplining trustees
when that is shouldn't not be the case
now we reached out to CCSD to ask if the
trustees would like to talk and talk and
take part in this story talk about this
story we did not hear back and trustee
Ford said she never got that message we
then also emailed specific trustees
individually and we did not receive
responses I'm David charns 8 News Now
David thank you CCSD elections are
nonpartisan three trustees are up for
re-election this November including
board president Cepeda and trustee Ford